what we have here is a display board
that features some hand-built and
hand-painted Warhammer 40k miniatures
that people use them during gameplay and
they also tell various stories with them
because they all have characters and
stuff like that what we have done is use
all winds to reality to enable people to
show beyond just what you see here the
deeper layers of meaning that might be
in there so how these things were built
what the characters are what story this
whole diorama is trying to tell so what
we have here is an augmented reality
application after you viewed the diorama
if you want to find out more about say
for example this character here can just
tap on him read about the character read
what he's done in various games so this
is dynamically collected data from
gameplay how he's done most memorable
moment for example it is augmented
reality so basically the content is tied
to the virtual content is tied to the
real world
you can come in from any angle view it
from anywhere we've got multiple tablets
so every going to at the same time where
does that start is it recognizing the
images what's going to be so augmented
reality so it is all about tying virtual
content to the real world now there are
a few ways to do this and barring it
barring any specialist equipment what
you can do is use optical techniques so
in this case we're just using the camera
nothing else and what it does is it
recognizes basically a two dimensional
image target in this case the stones in
front there's basically just a square
image of stones that we've taught the
app to recognize and based on that in
relation to that image we've placed the
virtual content as you can see when we
get closer to the individual cards they
become more opaque and easier to read so
it's a proximity thing so basically
we've told the system that compared to
say above that guy's head there's a
piece of information that we can tap on
and everything is in relation to that
image this of course has some
limitations but as technology gets
better the same technology can instead
of having to recognize a two dimensional
image can recognize the objects
themselves assuming you've thought of
what they look like the way it works is
while it is looking for a specific
target you don't need to stay locked on
to that target while you're viewing the
content this would be the default
before now it has acquired a lock and
see here we are no longer looking at the
image target which is what everything's
tied to but because it is using optical
flow we can go off the target and find
something in fact we can take the
content away basically and read it at
our leisure and when we're done it will
inform us that we're off target and you
might have seen the card flew back to
where the diorama was and we just go
back reacquire get what we want say read
about that guy so let's say it's really
busy in here and we just decide we want
to go and sit down on the sofa and keep
reading is that is that doable yes it is
however you will have to return to pick
up the content of somebody else when
you're done of course there is an
offline reading capability which is
basically just like reading a book but
there we go we can grab this and
assuming we unlocked this establish you
indeed it's one of those requirements
and there we go and they'll just fly
back to where it came from
ideally you'd be able to tie virtual
content to anything in real time so
obviously the sci-fi applications would
be I'm interested in something and I can
just have the information pop up above
it and I see it on my sci-fi Google
Glasses or whatever it might be
the trick is having technology that can
do that on the fly we're getting there
it's all based on game engine technology
so unity engine in this case then v4 is
such a which is a augmented reality
engine there's play very nicely together
and then it was a simple matter of
putting together the physical component
and all the content that was gonna be
there Tangut ah I'm putting you on
display
so on average we take about 100 images
per object again whatever the camera
doesn't see they cannot make a model off
so we try to make sure we get all the
hidden parts of the model then we throw
that into our software and we align the
images so each image